[Music]
a 103 year old man recently set a
guinness world
record for the oldest tandem skydiver
even crazier a 74 year old checked
himself out of the hospital
after leaving walter reed medical center
this week president trump appeared to
stage a second
re-entry into the white house for use in
a propaganda video
and we actually have a clip of it right
here
oh yeah
according to usa today due to the
coronavirus pandemic
holiday shopping is expected to start
earlier this year
said one holiday shopper
christmas stuff and decoration but i
need to do it right
do you remember she said that i have
forgotten
three different asteroids flew past
earth on wednesday
and each one of them was like uh no i
can't stop there that place is messy
and we are we are messy earth
spotify announced that listeners can now
search for songs
using lyrics which is fine but anybody
can do that
call me when you have an app that can do
this hey
what's that one song by that one guy and
it's like
i have no business listening to this
song but it really makes you turn
up in like a white way and then a black
lady starts singing and you're like
yes this is my [ __ ] uh oh oh oh um
wild night by john mellencamp and
michelle
degacello that is correct
and finally a college student in the uk
was rescued by firefighters
after she became stuck in a dryer while
under the influence of alcohol
even worse she shrunk
[Laughter]
you guys i have to admit that last joke
was a lie
she didn't drink she's still fine
but i mean for all i know well oh ooh i
take it back
we don't know she probably did shrink
she could be a shrinker scientifically
accurate the amber reference show every
last minute of it
but the biggest news of the week was
wednesday night's vice presidential
debate
between senator kamala harris and vice
president mike pence
some say what we witnessed that night
was an
informative debate some say what we
witnessed was a spirited debate
i say what we witnessed wasn't a debate
at all
but rather the dragging of a vice
president
pop stars get dragged real housewives
get dragged but vice presidents
uh yeah they do now senator kamala
harris is known for her highly effective
dragging but
with millions watching and so much at
stake she probably started the evening
out nice
right the american people have witnessed
what is the greatest failure of any
presidential administration in the
history of our country
oh ruthless right out the gate
now that's a sufficient drag if our
story ended there our hunger for
dragging would be satiated
but folks once kamala gets to dragon
there's no telling when she'll stop
she had this to say about a possible
covet vaccine if
the doctors tell us that we should take
it i'll be the first in line to take it
absolutely but if donald trump tells us
i should
that we should take it i'm not taking it
you know that made pence madder than the
time
he found out that women are allowed to
drive
now it's at this point when you think
well it's been a good debate
but this man has gotten dragged so
terribly surely he will go home now
but this full stayed around and i gotta
hand it to him
that is brave now this is what senator
harris said about the trump and pence
health care plan
if you have a pre-existing condition
heart disease
diabetes breast cancer they're coming
for you
if you love someone who has a
pre-existing condition thank you thank
you coming for you
if you are under the age of 26 on your
parents coverage
they're coming for you and if you have
pinkeye
kamala is coming for you
now how can she drag this 200-pound man
so easily
and why is she dragging him so terribly
is it because
he supports gay conversion therapy and
doesn't mind what's happening at the
border
or does she just love to stun on them
i don't know but i'm sure pence had a
good comeback
you're not entitled to your own facts
you yourself said on multiple
oh talk about bringing a noodle to a
gunfight
what are you doing boy just shut up and
take this whooping you're embarrassing
yourself
anyway let's get back to some good old
dragon we're about freedom and
respecting the freedom of the american
people
let's talk about respecting the american
people you respect the american people
when you tell them the truth
oh this is delicious now you may be
asking yourself
the tea or the dragon both baby
any hope of pence maintaining his
dignity all
came down to the next question vice
president pence you were in the front
row
in a rose garden event 11 days ago what
seems to have been a super spreader
event dang even the question
is that burn now you know you do a lot
of dirt when a person can't ask you a
question without the question
itself being a burn that's like if
someone came up to you and was like
why is your trash ass such trash
but you don't need to be a human being
to drag pence now
while he was busy mispronouncing brianna
taylor's name
this happened is a great insult
to the men and women who serve in law
enforcement
five five five five five fly fry fly fly
were you doing it that at home with your
husband the whole two minutes that fly
was on that guy
because we were in my house now
it's truly hilarious that mother nature
itself
cannot help but to drag this man you
love to see it
now it would take too long to show you
every dragging that took place wednesday
night so
i'll leave you with these final
highlights mr vice president i'm
speaking
i have i'm speaking mr vice president
i'm speaking
i'm speaking if you don't mind letting
me finish we can then have a
conversation
mr vice president i'm speaking i'm
speaking
okay so the next time you spend four
years
passing legislation that benefits rich
people while creating laws that hurt the
rest of america
you better cover your tracks or you
might end up a part of
the dragging of a vice president
now that's what hanging out with me and
tarik is like it is not for everyone
no okay you guys so a lot of crazy
things happened in the news this week
and
i felt bad because i had a lot of
negative feelings and
i don't want to be someone who has
negative feelings all the time
and i feel like i spent the whole week
trying not to wish
ill on people did you have that problem
oh oh really so when all those people
were coming down with that thing you
didn't feel like oh good
oh so when those folks got together with
no masks on and stood real close to one
another and celebrated the conservative
replacement of rbg in the middle of a
freaking pandemic and then they caught
it
you weren't like a little bit nope
no oh okay when kellyanne conway's
daughter called her
own mom out on tick-tock you were like
a little bit no okay
well when stephen miller got it you
weren't like texting everybody
talking about oh my gosh look what
happened to this literal white
supremacist
oh wow so you didn't make up a funny
little bingo card with a bunch of
republicans faces and send it around to
all your friends
i wouldn't even know how to come on i
don't know how to do that
so what's that piece of paper on your
stand right there
oh wow you're a better person than me
tarek
you're a better person than me would you
like to talk about how much better than
me you are
not no i'm
[Music]
you guys even though pretty much every
republican
tested positive for the coronavirus this
week including
two members of the senate judiciary
committee senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell
announced that he will move forward with
the confirmation hearing for supreme
court nominee amy coney barrett
now if barrett is confirmed the supreme
court will become more conservative than
it has been since
the 1930s and
do you know how conservative things were
in the 1930s i mean the supreme court is
about to get so
conservative conservative you say
oh tarik i'm talking plenty conservative
oh conservative i'm
talking super conservative ha ha
how conservative will it get it's gonna
get so
conservative that women will have the
right to choose what to spend their
allowance on
how conservative will it get it'll get
so conservative that the only sex you'll
have
is the one you're assigned at birth how
conservative will it get
it's going to get so conservative the
only health care you'll be able to
afford
is a cootie shine how conservative will
it get
it's going to get so conservative that
if you say i'm gay
you better not mean it like that how
conservative will it get
it's gonna get so conservative that roe
v wade is gonna be how you decide to get
to work
after they let the ice caps melt how
conservative will it get
it's gonna get so conservative that
straight white men will be like
huh i think something's a little wrong
how conservative will it get
it's gonna get so conservative that
church's chicken will become
actual churches how conservative will it
get it's gonna get so conservative
that we will wish we had done more to
prevent this from happening
and preserve the already endangered
rights of women
and minority
[Music]
[Applause]
it
groups
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you